here with reaction Senate Judiciary
Committee Chairman Lindsey Graham
senator how are you I am great that was
pretty well done thank you all right
I've got a good grade for my classroom
senator yes you did you know none of
this is even upsetting in the least to
me because this is who they are this
defines them this is this represents
everything they have done for three
years can you name one accomplishment
besides this if they want to consider
this an accomplishment this and and act
like they're not high-fiving bull that's
more [ __ ] too but anyway right well
so so here's the question why are they
doing this the reason they're doing it
is Nancy Pelosi would lose her job if
they did not move toward impeachment
what happened between March and now in
March we need to be thoughtful and
bipartisan impeachment should be a grave
decision made in a bipartisan manner
what happened the mob took over the
house the mob is running the Democratic
Party and if she did not move to impeach
this president she would not be speaker
so she picked her job over what's good
for the country and I hope at the end of
the day it costs the Democrats the house
and it's going to do a lot to reelect
the president their goal to destroy the
president is actually going to blow up
in their face they're going to make it
more likely that it gets four more years
and can you imagine what the judiciary
would look like with four more years of
Donald Trump yeah because he's he's
appointed a lot of judges I gotta get
Mitch McConnell that has been one of the
greatest accomplishments a him so we had
one fact witness every other witness was
a hearsay witness or an opinion witness
or an ivory tower professor witness that
wants to reach the president because he
once used the words fake and news in a
tweet so my question to you is okay what
goes to the Senate Mitch McConnell has
been very clear you've been very clear
some have asked me on radio TV they
write me what about Mitt Romney what
about Susan Collins of Maine up which I
think she needs the president's support
what about Lisa Murkowski or I don't
even know who else yeah
I know well here's what I think I think
I think Republicans are going to be very
reluctant to legitimize what the house
did because if you care about the
presidency as an institution what they
did in the house is really a threat to
the presidency
they started impeachment in the house
Intel committee the president's lawyer
was not present it was hearsay upon
hearsay behind closed doors selectively
leaking information the only actual fact
witness exonerated the president this is
the first impeachment done by partisan
politicians every other impeachment has
been driven by outside counsel spending
time and money looking in accusations
that resulted in criminal liability bill
clinton actually committed a crime
Donald Trump in Donald Trump's done
nothing wrong so I really think it's
going to be difficult for Republicans to
legitimize what the house did you know I
agree you don't all right so let's
assume you're gonna have House members I
guess whoever their team is they will
they will present their case and then
what happens well here's what's going to
happen this needs to be looked at as a
Supreme Court argument in our house
colleagues on the Republican side
Jordan Meadows Gates the whole list
Biggs you name it Radcliffe did a great
job exposing this sham but when we come
to the Senate we're gonna have the Chief
Justice of the United States sitting
presiding over the trial and this needs
to be presented to the Senate reasonably
and rationally based on facts and law
and here's what I hope the president
will do I hope he will law put a legal
team together that can tear this case
apart factually and legally we're going
to acquit the president I think it will
be bipartisan sooner rather than later
and the political consequences to this
will be felt in the next election play
this tape on election night I'll make a
prediction here the impeachment of this
president by Nancy Pelosi shiftin Nadler
will do as much to get Donald Trump
re-elected is that litany of
accomplishments senator thank you for
all you do and looking forward we'll
watch this closely in the new year